ME YOU WILL GO TO UNCLE
TOM.COM.
I CAN’T WAIT TO WEAR MY HAT ON
"HANNITY."
>> Sean: A LOT COMING I WOULD.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME ON.
>> Sean: YOU BEEN WATCHING THE
EVENTS OF TODAY, I’M JUST DYING
TO GET YOUR RESPONSE.
>> LISTEN, WHAT CAN YOU SAY
ABOUT BIDEN?
NO ONE COVERS HIM IN THE MEDIA
OTHER THAN YOU.
IT’S AN ABSOLUTE TRAVESTY.
WHEN HE SAYS THAT THE BLACK
COMMUNITY IS NOT DIVERSE,
ONE-DIMENSIONAL, WHEN HE COMES
OUT WITH THIS NONSENSE, CAN YOU
IMAGINE IF DONALD TRUMP SAID
THAT?
THE MEDIA DOESN’T EVEN WANT TO
COVER IT.
THAT IS HOW BIASED, THAT IS HOW
IN THEIR CORNER THEY ARE.
IT’S DISGUSTING.
HE DOESN’T HAVE THE MENTAL
CAPACITY TO BE COMMANDER IN
CHIEF OF THIS COUNTRY.
JOE BIDEN IS SPENDING MORE TIME
ON TV THAN HER HUSBAND’S.
THE GUY WON’T COME OUT OF HIS
BASEMENT, HE WON’T ANSWER REAL
QUESTIONS, WE ARE GOING TO HAVE
16 STATES, YOU’RE GOING TO HAVE
8 MILLION VOTES BEFORE THE FIRST
DEBATE AND IT’S DISGUSTING AND
IT SHOULDN’T HAPPEN AND IT’S A
TRAVESTY.
THIS GUY IS AFRAID OF MY FATHER
AND I REALLY BELIEVE THESE
DEBATES ARE GOING TO BE AN
ABSOLUTE BLOODBATH.
>> Sean: I WILL TELL YOU THIS,
I REALLY WOULD LIKE TO HAVE THAT
DEBATE.
I MEAN, I WOULD LIKE TO RESOLVE
THE ISSUES FROM 2016 ABOUT THE
DEEP STATE WITH YOUR DAD AND I
ALSO THINK IT’S FAIR THAT JOE
SAYS HE’S DYING TO DEBATE
DONALD TRUMP.
LET’S HAVE IT.
ADD THE EXTRA DEBATE, JOE.
DONALD TRUMP INVITED YOU TO HAVE
AN EXTRA DEBATE BEFORE ONE VOTE
IS CAST, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
NEED TO SEE THIS.
>> DO YOU THINK IT’S ANY
COINCIDENCE THAT ALL THE DEBATES
ARE AT THE END OF SEPTEMBER AND
INTO OCTOBER?
IF YOU LOOK IN NORTH CAROLINA, I
WILL GIVE YOU A GREAT EXAMPLE,
NORTH CAROLINA STARTS VOTING
SEPTEMBER 4TH.
WE LOOK AT FLORIDA, FLORIDA
STARTS VOTING SEPTEMBER 14TH,
RIGHT?
THE DEBATE DOESN’T HAPPEN UNTIL
SEPTEMBER 29TH.
THE FIRST DEBATE, AND THAT’S NOT
THE LAST DEBATE.
YOU ARE LITERALLY GOING TO HAVE
A MILLION VOTES BEFORE THE FIRST
DEBATE AND THEY RAKE THIS ON
PURPOSE.
THAT’S WHY YOU WON’T GET THE
DEBATE.
HE DOESN’T WANT TO DEBATE MY
FATHER, NO QUESTION ABOUT IT.
THAT’S WHAT HE WANTS TO DEBATE
AS LATE AS POSSIBLE BECAUSE THE
BENEFITS AND BECAUSE HE DOES NOT
WANT TO BE ON THE DEBATE STAGE.
WHEN YOU SEE THE COMMENTS HE
MADE TODAY ABOUT THE BLACK
COMMUNITY, WHEN YOU SEE THE
COMMENTS THE GUY MAKES
EVERYTHING THE DAY.
LAST WEEK HE CALLED ARIZONA A
CITY.
A COUPLE WEEKS AGO, HE SAID HE
WAS RUNNING FOR UNITED STATES
SENATE, SEAN.
THE GUY DOES NOT WANT TO DEBATE
MY FATHER AND IT’S A TRAVESTY
THAT THIS DEBATE COMMISSION IS
PROBABLY VERY, VERY CROOKED.
HE’S ALLOWING HIM TO START THE
DEBATE THIS FAR INTO VOTING.
>> Sean: THIS IS CORRUPTION AT
THE HIGHEST LEVEL.
THIS IS NOT FAIR TO THE AMERICAN
VOTER.
HE SWEARS HE WANTS TO DEBATE.
HE NEEDS TO DEBATE.
THE COUNTRY NEEDS TO SEE A
DEBATE BEFORE A SINGLE VOTE IS
CAST.
TOTALLY AGREE.
LAST WORD.
>> LISTEN, I THINK WE ARE
LOOKING REALLY GOOD, THE POLLS
ARE LOOKING GREAT.
YOU SEE IT EVERY DAY, THE
ENTHUSIASM IS TREMENDOUS.
I CAN TELL YOU, AS VOCAL AS A
LOT OF OUR SUPPORTERS ARE,
WHAT’S UNDER THE SURFACE IS
TREMENDOUS.
I CAN JUST SEE IT.
I SEE MORE ENTHUSIASM GOING INTO
2020 THAN I DID IN 2016.
WE ARE GOING TO WIN.
MY FATHER IS GOING TO WIN BACK
THE SELECTION.
>> Sean: HE’S GOT THE WHOLE
MEDIA MOB AND THE ESTABLISHMENT